- Hello, everyone.
I hope that you're doing well,
and thanks for joining us.
It's my great pleasure to
introduce Dr. Cindy Nguyen,
who is a wonderful colleague,
friend and a human being.
Dr. Nguyen earned her PhD
in History at UC Berkeley
and specializes in the history of Vietnam,
Southeast Asian print
culture and libraries.
Currently she's a postdoctoral fellow
in international humanities
in the department of history
and the Cogut Institute for
Humanities at Brown University
where she teaches innovative
virtual reality based courses
on Southeast Asian history.
And her book manuscript,
"Reading and Misreading:
The Social Life of Libraries
"and Colonial Control
in Vietnam, 1865-1958"
examines the cultural
and political history
of libraries in Hanoi and Saigon
from the French colonial period
through to the decolonization of libraries
through the lens of cultural imperialism,
national legitimacy, and social
practices of public reading.
She has presented for
scholarship internationally,
including in the US,
Vietnam, and Singapore.
In her essay,
"The Social Life of the
Hanoi Central Library:
"Reading Cultures in
Public Space, 1919 to 1941"
won the Association for Asian Studies'
Pattana Kitiarsa Southeast
Asian Council Prize in 2020.
In addition to being a scholar, Dr. Nguyen
is also a digital humanist,
an artist, a poet,
a translator, a filmmaker,
a publisher, a feminist and a refugee.
She seamlessly weaves these dimensions
into provocative and
beautiful multimedia work,
including short films that meditate
on intergenerational transmissions
of language, love and loss.
Dr. Nguyen is currently working
on a poetic documentary film
on the language of Vietnamese
refugee remembrance
and history.
And since this brief
introduction does not do justice
to the breadth and depth of
Dr. Nguyen's intellectual
and creative endeavors,
please do visit her websites,
and I'll drop those in the chat for you
for more information and
access to her wonderful work.
Today, Dr. Nguyen's talk is titled,
"The Politics of Good Reading:
"Libraries and the Public
in Late Colonial Vietnam."
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Nguyen.
- Thank you so much for that introduction.
It's truly an honor to
be introduced by Quan
who is really, just makes me remember
all the different types
of collaborative work
that we've done together
and really to just to celebrate
the different types of
things that I've done
in terms of my pedagogy and research.
So thank you again, Quan.
I want to also take this
opportunity to thank you,
Quan, Eric, and Chris for inviting me
to be part of this brown bag series.
I truly appreciate this opportunity
to be in virtual intellectual
community with all of you
and to share this work in progress.
I very much look forward to the Q&A
to elaborate on this work as well
as the larger book manuscript.
So I'm just gonna take a second
to set up share screen and
not multitask while doing this
to make sure everything's good.
So again, thank you for this opportunity.
I'm Cindy Nguyen, a cultural
historian of Vietnam libraries
and print culture.
Today's talk, I will first discuss
the main research
questions and interventions
of my book manuscript titled "Misreading."
I'll share an excerpt from the book,
focus on the case study
of the 1930s to 1940s,
Book Wagons Bibliobus project
in Cochinchina, southern Vietnam.
And I'll conclude with a discussion
on the book's chapters,
scope, and major contributions
to the field.
So my book project title "Misreading,"
examines the cultural and
political history of libraries
and print control in
Vietnam from 1865 to 1958.
I analyze the changing
mission of colonial libraries
as a hybrid of state documentation
and a public space for
self-directed education
and social life.
Focused primarily on the
state Central Library in Hanoi
and the Cochinchina Library in Saigon
shown here in this slide.
This book advances a two-part argument
on the history of libraries
and print control in Indochina
which today consists of
Vietnam, Cambodia, Laos.
First to build libraries
is to build the state.
Libraries legitimize the
authority of the state
as infrastructures of symbolic modernity,
print control and documentary heritage.
Second, library users also
shape the everyday mission
and social function of the library
beyond these hegemonic aspirations
of colonial and post-colonial states.
This study demonstrates
how builders and users
articulated a meaning of public
through the functions of
the colonial state libraries
to serve its readers, to
preserve documentary heritage,
and to operate as a broader instrument
of public education and moralization.
This two-part argument
reveals the significance
of the library as an
institution of state-building,
print control and public reading culture.
This book is the first
comprehensive history
of the library in Southeast Asia.
The narrative is book-ended
by two formative events,
the founding of the Cochinchina
French colonial library
in 1865, which was the first
colonial state public library
in Indochina and the centralization
of the National Library
of the new Republic of Vietnam
in 1958, South Vietnam.
So this chronology
challenges externally-defined
chronologies,
such as 1945 World War II,
1954, the end of the first Indochina war,
and completely offers this
new frame of reference
in understanding into
processes of colonization
and decolonization
and creation of
post-colonial nation States
from the perspective of Vietnam.
In terms of source material,
I primarily used newspapers,
official archives, reader
statistics in Vietnam and France.
My top-down and bottom-up
analysis of library builders
and users contributes to the findings
of the colonial state libraries,
public and urban space,
knowledge, curation, and print culture.
With attention to labor, access and space,
the book sheds sight on the
politics of gender and race
in libraries, as well as its legacies
in post-colonial nation
building in Vietnam.
So as a way to illuminate the arguments
of the book manuscript, I will focus
on the specific case study
of the mobile library
wagon project in
Cochinchina, South Vietnam
in 1930s to 1940s.
On March, 1936, the first Bibliobus
or mobile library book wagon in Indochina
began its journey through
nine provinces in Cochinchina.
The library wagons circulated 832 French
and Vietnamese books
of popular literature,
politics, morality, and science
from the Cochinchina's Saigon library.
Every two months the book wagon toured
through the nine provinces,
lending books to Vietnamese
and French readers.
A Vietnamese driver and secretary
from the Cochinchina library
accompanied the wagon.
The book wagon encountered
many delays and accidents.
For example, on September 1st, 1937,
on the way from Bà Rịa to Biên Hòa
the book wagon struck a tree stump
when swerving to avoid
hitting a seven-year-old girl
who was in the road.
The accident severely damaged the wagon,
delaying the trip for one month
while the vehicle underwent
extensive repairs.
The Bibliobus book wagon
continued its route
on November 15th, 1937 from Saigon
through the western Mekong Delta region
following this schedule.
So in this schedule here,
you see that this is the
first mobile book wagon,
after its repairs departing from Saigon.
Note the limited operating
hours of the mobile wagon
at each stop as well the central location
in front of administrative
offices, schools and hospitals.
Over the course of the year,
the mobile book wagon served
a total of 10,000 readers.
Due to the success of
the first book circuit
on December, 1937 a
second mobile book wagon
traveled through eight other provinces
of Cochinchina, (listing foreign names).
The second mobile wagon served
a total of 21,500 readers
over the course of one year.
The story of the mobile book
wagons seems particularly
ambitious and curious.
Why did the governmental and
public Cochinchina library
circulate its valuable
collections to the countryside?
What books moved from the
urban center of Saigon
to the provinces?
Who were the readers and
what did they check out?
A closer examination of this
peculiar project sheds light
on the geographic and symbolic extension
of the colonial state into the countryside
through physically bringing
quote good reading to the people.
Good reading, I argue was
a changing political moral
and literary concept
advanced by the French
and Vietnamese government administrators,
librarians, publishers,
writers, as well as readers.
This talk offers three discoveries.
First it reveals how
high level administrators
in the Indochina library director advanced
a cultural propaganda project
to disseminate good reading
as didactic, politically safe,
and vulgarizing reading
matter to the countryside
through book wagons.
Secondly, I show
how this state initiated
book wagons project
intersected with the development
of Vietnamese reading
public actively enmeshed
in global translated literature
in French and Vietnamese
as well as a growing body Quoc Ngu,
a Romanized script Vietnamese literature.
Thirdly, I reveal a vibrant
Vietnamese public sphere
who debated the role of good reading
and called for the development
of Quoc Ngu library collections
for the larger Vietnamese public.
My primary research
question is the following:
What role did the official state library
such as the Cochinchina library
and then also the Hanoi Central Library
play within this larger
landscape of print culture
and reading public in
the late colonial period?
This talk on the Bibliobus
mobile wagon project,
as well as the larger book manuscript
points to the mechanics,
the discourse in everyday
practice of the library
to fulfill its role as an
official government institution,
a resource of public education,
and a cultural space for the practice
of collective responsibility,
urban civility
and public reading.
From 1928 to 1930, the French
colonial administration
drew inspiration from the existing
Balai Pustaka state
sponsored publishing bureau,
distribution office and library system
in the Dutch East Indies, today Indonesia.
Governor General of
Indochina, Pierre Pasquier,
commissioned extensive studies
on the Dutch East Indies publishing
and popular libraries projects,
seeking to implement a similar
project in French Indochina.
Emile Vayrac, the Director of the Office
of Indigenous Publishing
and the Resident Superior
at the resident superior
of Tonkin, North Vietnam.
He studied the Balai Pustaka in Indonesia
and evaluated the current
state of publishing and print
in Indochina.
Vayrac argued that
beginning these publications
perpetuated dangerous criticisms
of French colonization
and civilization.
He quotes, "Vietnamese literary
production is struggling
"in anarchy and drags
itself into insignificance.
"Apart from some
republications of old poems
"or ancient moral guides,
small number of serious works,
"the majority of Vietnamese
print criticizes us,"
the French, "and speaks
poorly of our civilization."
Praising the Dutch East
Indies, Vayrac argued
that the Balai Pustaka created libraries
and schools, police stations, hospitals,
and instituted an office of publishing,
which produced and
distributed good reading
throughout the country.
Colonial administrators, such
as Vayrac were keenly aware
and threatened by the rise and influence
of anti-colonial sentiment
and political organizing
in Indochina in the 20's and the 30's.
In his essay,
the "Program for the Recovery
of the Public Spirit,"
from his report, Vayrac elaborated
on the colonial administration's anxieties
over Vietnamese radicalism.
Vayrac described the existing threat
of rapid revolutionary political ideas,
Chinese influence, anti-French sentiment
among a growing generation
of dangerous, young
urban Vietnamese radicals
eager for change, as seen in this slide.
Vayrac called attention
to the pervasiveness
of Bolshevik and anti-French agitation
amongst urban Vietnamese
especially students, workers, youth.
The spirit of subversion
undermined the Vietnamese family,
corrupted the minds of young students,
and could potentially
permeate into the countryside.
Within this context of
increased radicalism,
the colonial administration
developed new strategies
to control the quickly spreading
evil of insubordination
amongst outspoken Vietnamese.
Vayrac believe that carefully crafted
and widespread propaganda messages
could counter the rising
political anti-French
and revolutionary sentiment
in the Vietnamese urban youth.
As seen in this slide,
Vayrac created this
indirect propaganda strategy
where he emphasized the importance
of the rural population,
the group that he considered
not only the humble,
true people of Indochina,
but also the population most vulnerable
to the political ideologies
propagated by urban intellectuals.
Vayrac suggested two effective methods
of indirect propaganda,
propaganda through action
and propaganda by imagery and appearance.
This essay concludes with an attached list
of European works to
translate to Vietnamese.
Vayrac argued that the
best works to translate
for Vietnamese readers
should include French popular literature
from the middle ages such
as tales of Perrault,
La Fontaine's fables, Renard's novels,
moral and educational
works as well as Proverbs.
This list focused primarily
on instructional
apolitical texts he called
that could civilize and morally
uplift Vietnamese readers.
The colonial state saw
direct political interest
in indigenous publishing and libraries
to produce and disseminate
a pro-colonial message.
Vayrac's study is only one of the examples
of extensive documentation from
the colonial administration
that show how control of
publishing and libraries
was essential as a propaganda tool
for the colonialist state.
At the same time of this
process with Vayrac,
the Director of Archives
and Libraries, Paul Boudet
initiated efforts to create
provincial libraries,
a distribution network and
book wagons or Bibliobus,
through the existing infrastructure
of the state directorate library
system in Hanoi and Saigon.
I'll now discuss a bit
of contextual background
on the library system in Indochina
and the role of Paul Boudet.
The vision and organization
of the Indochina library
was deeply shaped
by the first and only colonial
era director Paul Boudet.
Paul Boudet graduated
from the renowned archives
and library school in Chartres
in 1909 as an archivist paleographer.
On November 30th, 1917
Boudet was appointed
as Director of the newly centralized
Directorate of Archives
and Libraries in Indochina,
which, sorry, in Hanoi.
So that was based in Hanoi.
Paul Boudet was also the head director
of the Hanoi central
library opened in 1919,
which operated both as an extension
of the Bibliothèque nationale in France
and as an Indochina state library
in the colonial capital of Hanoi.
Paul Boudet standardized
technical and administrative policies
for documentation in IndoChina.
Most importantly, Boudet
defined the function and mission
of a modern library based
off of French libraries.
He argued that encyclopedic libraries
must assemble the best works
of all levels of knowledge,
an orderly stable and
comprehensive collections.
A modern library followed
French model of libraries,
he argued specifically the BNF,
the Bibliothèque nationale,
to provide scientifically
classified best works
to the greater public.
Boudet sought to implement these visions
to all the regional
libraries in Indochina,
the Hanoi Central Library, the
Cochinchina Central Library,
as well as the Phnom
Penh Cambodia library.
Throughout the colonial period though,
the vision and reality
of the colonial library
as modern, encyclopedic, and public
often differed in practice.
Many of these libraries
such as the Cochinchina library in Saigon
originated first as a government library
to provide documentation,
reference matter,
and reading leisure for
French administrators
and at times their wives
who had relocated to Saigon.
Yet by 1920s and 1930s,
an increasing number of
Vietnamese university students,
commercial workers, and researchers
sought to access these
valuable library collections.
Furthermore library administrators debated
what type of good reading should be added
to the library collection.
Libraries encountered budget constraints
to build collections and hire staff.
They also ran out, often
ran out of space for storage
and offered a limited number
of seats in the reading room
as pictured here in the
Cochinchina library,
which was housed in the cramped
government secretariat building together
with the archives in Cochinchina.
In 1938, the reading
room held a collection
of 36,000 volumes.
Although constrained by a
limited number of 44 seats,
the reading room was able
to welcome over 133 readers
each day.
During 1938, the popular lending section
recorded a total of 31,000
borrowers and 55,000 book loans.
Since the founding
of the Directory of Archives
and Libraries in 1917,
Boudet had envisioned an expansive network
of provincial libraries
throughout Indochina.
Inspired also by the Balai
Pustaka in Indonesia,
the Governor General Pierre Pasquier
officially enlisted Boudet
to research public libraries
and book wagons around the world.
On March 28th, 1929 Paul Boudet wrote
to the American Library
Association office in Paris
and requested documents
to study American circulating book wagons
and shipment service
in order to develop a
similar project in Vietnam.
Boudet was particularly interested
in the practical cost efficient
methods used by automobiles
for the distribution of books.
From here begins an
extensive exchange of letters
between Boudet and libraries
from all around the world.
Boudet received extensive
replies and research resources
from the ALA, the American
Library Association in Paris,
the office in Chicago, even
the California State Library
in Sacramento.
American libraries shipped
hundreds of recent pamphlets,
legal documents, book
catalogs and newspapers
for Boudet to study the organization
of circulating libraries
and book wagons in America.
These resources explore topics such
as the curatory
responsibility of librarians,
the importance of literacy
and access to useful
knowledge such as technology
or technical books.
Boudet also wrote to the
Metropolitan Library in Beijing
in China, the Central
Library in Baroda, India
to request information
on their circulating libraries program.
This points to the significant ways
in which models for library development
was a transnational process,
not always stemming from
metropole to colony.
From these comparative library models,
Boudet proposed his
circulating library project
which consists of the following:
lending of French and Quốc
ngữ, a Romanized Vietnamese,
a popular script of spoken Vietnamese,
books from the provinces,
and the distribution of the
provinces, to the provinces
these books and pamphlets
published by indigenous writers
under official control.
Recognizing the high cost of this project,
Boudet emphasized the potential
of a circulating library system
to provide the European
indigenous population,
the provinces, a healthy leisure activity.
Additionally, Boudet argued
that the circulating library
project combat the spread
of politically dangerous reading matter
among Vietnamese readers,
such as works inspired by
Bolshevik propaganda pamphlets
widely distributed in China,
he says in this slide.
Similar to Vayrac's proposal
for counter propaganda initiatives,
Boudet argued that circulating libraries
could also combat the dangerous influence
of Chinese revolutionary texts.
This counter propaganda strategy
sought to increase the
availability of safe texts
through state sponsored
distribution, libraries
and publishing in hopes that these texts
would flood the Vietnamese print market.
By making safe reading
matter more plentiful,
colonial administrators
and Boudet hoped to compete
with the popularity of
illicit reading matter
amongst Vietnamese.
Throughout the 1930s, the Governor General
and local administration
continued to discuss, debate,
revise, and implement aspects
of the comprehensive project
to develop popular libraries,
an office of publishing as
well as a book wagons project.
Yet an entirely centralized,
evenly distributed system
never materialized throughout Indochina
due to economic crises,
political insurrections,
and a rapid turnover in
political administration.
Yet Boudet continued to
organize circulating book wagons
throughout the 30's and early 40's,
albeit with fiscal limitations.
Here, for example, is a
photograph of a book wagon
circulating secular and Buddhist texts
from the Royal Library in Cambodia
that was organized by another
scholar administrator,
Suzanne Karpelès, the curator
of the Buddhist Institute
and Royal Library in
Cambodge through the 1930s.
This book wagon pictured on the left
circulated thousands of volumes
throughout the Southeast Cambodia,
Southwest Cochinchina region.
In comparison the Cambodge
Library pictured on the right
was functioned more as
the administrative archive
and reference library.
The Directorate continued to organize
these circulating library
services sporadically in the 40's,
especially throughout South
Vietnam, Cochinchina region.
A 1946 report argued that
circulating libraries
brought French culture to
the outer isolated regions
of Cochinchina, which served
as a healthy leisure activity.
The report estimated
that throughout 36 to 46,
the circulating libraries
brought than 23,000 books
to the provinces.
In 1942, just to zoom
in a little bit more,
to get a sense of the readers
and the reader tastes.
In over 22 provinces as far as
(listing Vietnamese provinces)
participated in the
circulating library project
based out of the Saigon
Cochinchina library.
For example, the August
1942 borrowing lists
from the port province of Rạch Giá
recorded 31 total borrowers for the month
of which two were French men,
one was a Vietnamese woman,
and the remaining 28
readers were Vietnamese men.
Most of the books borrowed
were French popular novels
such as pop fiction on romance,
police stories, espionage,
by Delly, translations
of popular literature
like the work of Agatha
Christie, Pearl S. Buck
and Leo Tolstoy, as well as
French language historical works
on Napoleon and Caesar, books
on science and geography.
In terms of Quốc Ngữ,
Vietnamese language works,
the materials checked out
were instructional texts
as well as new popular Vietnamese novels.
As seen in this slide
these book wagon numbers
point to what Peter Zimmerman has termed
as a provincial cosmopolitanism
of popular, global and French literature
networked in Vietnam.
And my research adds to this analysis
by highlighting the logistical
movement of these texts
into the countryside.
Furthermore, the book wagon's
circulation records show
how the booming Vietnamese
Quốc Ngữ print market
of new popular literature such as those by
Vietnamese Southern writer Hồ Biểu Chánh.
My research on the Bibliobus reveals
how these new experimental
forms of looking at literature
primarily produced in the urban centers
of Hanoi and Saigon
extended geographically,
moving and conceptualizing
the Vietnamese reading public
into the countryside.
Another major argument that I advance
is that the development of libraries
was not simply a French-initiated project
but involved a larger community
of Vietnamese publishers,
journalists and literary figures
who called for the
development of libraries
for the larger Vietnamese
language reading public.
In 1942, Khuong Viet
drafted an extensive program
to create a Quốc Ngữ library system
throughout the three regions of Vietnam
and published this four page
essay featured prominently
in the popular colonial
periodical "Tri Tan."
Khuong Viet was the penname
of Saigon-based journalist
and writer and Ngô Chân Lưu
who had worked in the Saigon library
in the 40's as well as
participated in associations
for the advancements of Quốc Ngữ.
In his essay, he directly
draws a connection
between the development
of Quốc Ngữ libraries
and the advancement of
Vietnamese civilization
and collective identity.
The first part of the essay
establishes the pervasiveness
of Quốc Ngữ and the patriotic
responsibility of each person
in the country to serve
and improve the language,
"since it directly
connects to the progress
"of the motherland, " he quotes.
Taking a closer analysis of his essay,
as shown in this quote, Viet
points to the importance
of spreading Quốc Ngữ works
to the larger collective
and uses a tone emphasizing
the urgent necessity
to think beyond the individual
and towards the collective.
Viet framed the libraries
project as a collective duty.
He says, "I have been able
to superfluously enjoy
"these priceless spiritual nourishments.
"I must not be selfish and
only enjoy these Quốc Ngữ works
"for myself.
"I must do something
so that my compatriots
"less fortunate than I
who do not have money
"to even witness and see these
valuable works of Quốc Ngữ
"can benefit from these
books along with me."
At the foundation of this project,
Khuong Viet outlines a collective concept
of the Vietnamese public tied deeply
to the dutiful involvement
of the collective public
or the Quan chung,
for the mass general benefit,
regardless of class,
religion and politics.
The author subtly critiques
existing libraries
in Indochina, stating that
private libraries of associations
only permitted access to its members
while the state Hanoi Central Library
made it difficult to enter and access
its Quốc Ngữ collection.
Khuong Viet described his proposed project
as a Quốc Ngữ new library
network with central libraries
first in Hanoi and Saigon,
bridging into provincial
libraries and then a book wagon,
bringing books to provinces and villages.
Furthermore Viet argues
that the preservation
of Quốc Ngữ books are part of a project
to preserve Vietnamese culture.
In analyzing this important essay,
I point to the relationship
between individual and collective duty
and how it intersects with the
consciousness of the public
and a sense of Vietnamese
collective evolution
as seen on the bottom of this slide.
Furthermore, Viet's
argument and word choice
emphasizes how the public
work of building a library
could also contribute
to a broader cultural and national project
of defining and preserving a
sense of Vietnamese culture
through Quốc Ngữ collections.
Viet proposes circulating
library or book wagons initiative
which would bring Quốc
Ngữ books and newspapers
directly to distant villages and hamlets.
Viet described this as a
good popularization effort
to bring the villager useful knowledge
for the betterment of their lives.
It's not surprising that
the proposed project
mirrors that of the
existing directorate system
and the proposals from Boudet,
given Viet's experience
working in the Saigon library.
Yet, so a lot of his
model, his proposed system
was modeled off of the
existing state Hanoi
and Saigon libraries.
Yet, the proposed system
distinguished itself
from the state libraries
due to its emphasis firstly
on Quốc Ngữ collections
and secondly on the
collective monetary investment
from the wider Vietnamese public.
Furthermore Viet points
to the cultural capital
of the library as an
appealing gathering place
for the ultimate literary coterie
of Vietnamese educated
youth, writers, thinkers,
and elite readers.
This project is significant
because it points
to how the creation of public
library was at its foundation
a collective endeavor tied to
Vietnamese national community
and responsibility of compatriots
to cultivate, protect
and share that identity
according to Viet.
About a week after Viet's article,
the journalist and scholar
of literature and history
Hoa Bang, expanded Khuong Viet's proposal
to include building reading societies
in the countryside.
Also publish in "Tri Tan,"
the article (Vietnamese name)
the city outskirts and the countryside
need these reading societies explain
that existing library
initiatives only serve
a limited minority of urban
readers literate in French.
The author also criticizes
the Hanoi Central Library
as restrictive, given
it's simplistic focus
on French material and
thus limiting its influence
to only a few and failing to provide
a universal service to all.
Building upon Viet's linguistic demands
for more Quốc Ngữ libraries,
Bang also calls for
development of these reading spaces
beyond the urban confines
and into the rural outskirts
and countryside communities.
Specifically Hoa Bang argues
that cultivating reading
practices had a moralizing benefit
and thus should be universally applied
across geographic reaches.
Firstly, you notice is how
the creation of libraries
supported good leisure
and thus could offset
bad leisure behaviors.
Besides the promotion of
healthy leisure activities,
Bang emphasized that every
day tastes must be cultivated
for the good of humanity.
You can see this in the quote here
where he discusses reading
books as an antidote
to bad leisure practices
such as going to taverns.
Building upon the metaphor
of reading as eating,
Hoa Bang represents books
as desirable food objects
with attractive senses,
spiritual nourishment
in the second quote here in this slide.
He notes how urban readers
already have a certain addiction
to this type of literary consumption.
Hoa Bang proposed that reading
societies could be built
in the existing temples of literature
and shrines in the villages and hamlets.
He draws heavily from
Confucian values of scholarship
and examination to argue
that the inherent value
of literature and reading
honored through the creation
of these reading societies.
Quoting a popular aphorism
among exam laureates
that translates as, "Even
if a child is stupid,
"they must still try to
study and read literature."
Hoa Bang declares
how proposed reading
societies carry on the wishes
of Vietnamese scholarly ancestors.
Similar to Viet's proposal,
Bang concludes this essay
with a statement that the
Quốc Ngữ Library project
ultimate benefits, the public, the people.
He calls for the individual
districts to sacrifice
50% of their budget used for festivals
to contribute to the developing
of these library projects.
The Bibliobus book wagons
project is significant
because firstly it situates the library
within the landscape of print culture
and geography of colonial control.
And secondly, it points to
the administrative exchanges
between Imperial projects
and international library sciences.
I reveal the diffuse negotiations
and fragmented implementation
of an official system
to control the publishing
and distribution of print
through Indochina, motivated
by indirect propaganda.
These projects decentralized print control
emerge out of colonial fears
of rising urban radicalism
as well as anti-colonial
revolutionary ideologies.
In comparison Director of the Archives
and Libraries, Paul Boudet,
focused on expanding access
to quote "apolitical reading
matter for the countryside
"through circulating book wagons."
Boudet directly engaged with international
current and library practices
to bring good reading
directly to the people geographically,
drawing from the US, France, England,
the movement saw the
creation of public libraries
as the actualization
of the state commitment
to its citizens, access to
modern, valuable knowledge,
and expansion of public
services into the countryside.
Boudet presented his book wagons project
as one of vulgarization and
benevolent modernization.
In this way the mission
and everyday reality
of colonial library carried
this inherently contradictory
ambiguous role.
The library reflected
state visions of control
modernian power, yet at the same time,
the library advances benevolent mission
of popular modern education,
allowing for self-directed
selection of reading matter
and adapted to demands for public access.
But most importantly, my
close study of Bibliobus
sheds light on the mechanics
of books circulation
and the literary tastes
of Vietnamese readers
in the provinces.
I trace the mechanics of book circulation
of book wagons project
and illuminate how Vietnamese readers
engage with this
provincial cosmopolitanism
of reading global literature,
as well as Vietnamese new literary forms
in the urban centers of Hanoi and Saigon.
I uncover the vibrant debates
amongst Vietnamese intellectuals
on the pages of "Tri Tan"
who called out the failures
of colonial state projects
to provide adequate and
equal library access
and Quốc Ngữ reading materials
to the Vietnamese public
especially those in the countryside.
These intellectuals
proposed a distinct meaning
of the public, rooted in
a collective consciousness
through the selfless act of
building literary collections,
specifically in Quốc Ngữ.
This tied national identity
to linguistic identity
and Quốc Ngữ as a national
language of the masses.
Emphasizing the inherent
value of Quốc Ngữ texts,
Khuong Viet and Hoa Bang
define Vietnamese good reading
as a collective project
that involved all Vietnamese
including those in the countryside,
beyond the urban centers
of Hanoi and Saigon.
Good reading was not just texts,
but was a way of defining,
modernizing and uplifting
Vietnamese leisure practices,
spiritual influences
and intellectual nourishment.
Furthermore, good reading
and the preservation
of Quốc Ngữ libraries contributed
to defining a Vietnamese
collective cultural identity
and historical temporality
from pre-colonial Confucian
scholarly traditions
into the present and into the future.
So this excerpt formed a key component
of my fourth chapter on the
politics of good reading
and print control.
In the brief remaining time,
I'm just going to breeze through
and zoom out a little bit
on how this fits into the
larger manuscript project.
So in this reading, as a book project,
the chapters follow a chronological
and thematic structure.
The first focusing on builders,
then the readers, popular
libraries, print control,
the excerpt I read today,
and then concluding with decolonization.
Each chapter considers the relationship
between print control and the public
as well as thinking about
the historical development
of libraries as spaces
of reading, education
and documentation.
Given this limited time,
I'll just briefly discuss
the scope of the first two
chapters and last chapter.
So for example, in chapter one,
I establish the histories,
vision and key personnel
of the four central institutions
examined in the book:
the Saigon Cochinchina library,
the Hanoi Central Library,
Phnom Penh library
in Cambodia, and the Directorate
of Archives and Libraries
in Indochina.
I argue that French colonialism gave rise
to new types of hybrid
library institutions
shaped by the changing
politics of the colonial state
and library standards of print control.
I pay particular attention
to both high level
labor, trained in France
in library sciences
and to the tech economy
such as the Chartres
Administrators in this slide.
But I also pay particular attention
to the training of Vietnamese laborers
as seen in this slide.
As a counter narrative to the
first chapter on builders,
this chapter focuses on
library users and experiences
in the Central Hanoi Library
and Cochinchina Library in Saigon.
I focus on the symbolic
and experience architecture
of the library.
This chapter sheds light on the ways
that the library reader
bodies were made modern.
They're legible, quieted,
restricted and monitored.
Specifically I examined race, space,
restrictions to library
access, and regulations
on proper behavior to
demonstrate the contradiction
of colonial Republican
project to modernize
through exclusion and racial hierarchy.
Yet by the 20s and 30s,
Vietnamese students became
the majority of library users
and subverted this colonial
vision of the library
as an exclusive space for French readers,
colonial administrators
and scholarly researchers.
I argue that the Vietnamese library users
redefined the meaning
of modern public space
by contesting library reading
roles, demanding reform
and increased access and
re-inscribing the actual
and symbolic space of the library
through everyday behavior.
I continue on through the chapters
to conclude with decolonization
where I examine the decolonization
of this elaborate Directorate
of Archives and Libraries
in Indochina
as well as the nationalization
of central libraries
in the democratic Republic
of Vietnam in Hanoi
and the Republic of Vietnam in Saigon.
I reveal how decolonization
was this fragmented process
embedded within the
logistical movement of people,
reading matter and
physically creating spaces
as well as the redefinition
of colonial institutions
in a post-colonial national landscape.
So here you have a photograph
of President Ngo Dinh Diem
inaugurating the building
of this new ambitious
national library project
and cultural center in Saigon in 1956.
And this was actually
built on the former site
of the colonial prison.
So just to summarize,
as shown in this visual
through the book, I
uncover how the library
is at the center of two
intertwined processes:
the development of the
colonial state and the public.
This dynamic history of the library
in colonial and post-colonial Vietnam
reveals a hybrid model of state libraries,
which are constantly negotiating
between different information systems,
different visions of reading
public, access and education,
as well as the role of
modern state institutions.
So taking a larger step back
and transitioning into Q&A,
I just wanted to share
what's been on my mind
as I worked through the
book manuscript revisions
and thinking of the library
as this analytical lens.
So I'm working on how
the library allows us
to understand larger cultural, social
and literary processes.
So firstly, I situate the library
within reading and print culture
and reveal how libraries
are important sites
of cosmopolitan and textual exchange,
as well as understanding the
different historic processes
of language learning and development
of French and Vietnamese.
And in ways that are part of
the landscape of other spaces
that are occurring during this time,
bookshops, associations,
clubs, temples and schools,
but also libraries are distinct
because of the nature
of how individuals read
through self-selection and
self-directed reading matter,
as well as public reading
practices in institutional spaces
such as in Hanoi and Saigon libraries.
For the second point, I'm investigating
the role of libraries as an institution
of state documentation of its subjects
and evolving bureaucratic
technical practices.
Here I seek to contribute new insight
into the field of library
science and information history
where I approach the
concept of the library
as both a material repository
and a set of technical,
cultural, and social practices.
And lastly, how I engage
with my archival newspaper
and literary source material
is to provide a cultural history
of urban public spaces and
practices of public reading.
Specifically that means investigating
and paying attention to the ways
in which these historical
actors are occupying
or reclaiming space in ways
that are often not intended
by administrators.
Thinking about these spaces
as social or leisure spaces,
idle spaces, how individuals
seem to constantly be breaking,
breaking rules in the library, providing,
being noisy, being disorderly,
disrupting other readers,
but also the ways in which the spaces
are gendered and racialized.
So, I mean, that's just
by way of conclusion
which are the concepts that
are evolving in my mind.
I very much look forward to Q&A
as well as just any other
questions about my work
and how it intersects with yours
or as well as just meeting
all of the attendees here.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you, Cindy Nguyen.
I will help moderate the Q&A session.
So if you could please
use the raised hand.
There's already a couple
of questions in the chat,
and then we'll queue up the questions.
And we ask that, you
know, if you could please
go on camera and and direct
your question to Dr. Nguyen.
So first up we have Professor Hue-Tam Tai.
who's dropped two questions
in here for Cindy.
So could you please raise your
question, Professor Hue Tai?
- I have quite a few questions
because your project is
really interesting to me.
The first one was, was
the Bibliobus a project
meant to counter specifically
the influence of Vietnamese journalism
that originated in the cities
but was spread through the provinces,
especially after the wave
of protest of 1926, 1927?
So since the Bibliobus project
seems to have been launched
in 1928, was there, you know, the idea
of countering these
protests and the influence
of young Franco-Annamite
trained protesters
in the countryside?
So that's my first question.
And I hope that your work
does address that question.
- Well, firstly, thank you so much
for raising that question,
and your book on radicalism
definitely has informed and
shapes a lot of my work.
So the short answer is partially yes.
A large significant part
of the the description
specifically from Vayrac
about urban intellectuals
and even like the coining
or the framing of radicalism
and Bolshevik ideologies
was very much a discussion
about the specific response
to the influence of Vietnamese journalism
and the protests in 26, 27.
So I say partially yes
because the other aspect of this project
was that it was a continual
large scale project
involving many actors, of course,
Pierre Pasquier and Vayrac,
but then also several other,
several other colonial administrators.
And then the focus on looking
at Indonesia as an example,
or the Dutch East Indies as an example
of how to elaborate and create
this system to counter this
was also kind of intersected and,
intersected with those protests
but also pre-dated those protests as well
because there were initiatives
looking at indigenous
publishing since the early 20's.
The specifics of Vayrac as
he talks about the urban
versus rural tension and sense of threat
was definitely a response to the protest.
But I just wanted to situate
this in a longer history
of thinking about indigenous publishing
and forms of subsidizing and
promoting different types
of quote, politically
safe texts and publishing.
And then the second part of this,
of the ways in which the project pre-dated
and expanded beyond the specifics
of these 26, 27 protests
is in the role of Boudet
who actually had proposed
the Bibliobus, the book
wagons project since 1917
and then later since 1919.
So he envisioned forms of
at least distributing books
and the mechanism of how
one could distribute books
by drawing from a more
global library approach
of looking at public libraries
and book wagons that was stemming from
the American Library Association
and stuff like rural libraries
projects that were developed
in America, actually since
the turn of the 19th century.
So then there's different
initiatives that are happening
at the same time.
And I think that's why this chapter was,
or this excerpt was so
hard to parse through
is that there wasn't one
singular justification,
and the justification is varied
because Boudat when talking
to Pasquier, of course,
like framed his book wagons project
as one of counter prop, like
ways of countering radicalism
but actually in practice often
he was just discussing the ways in which
how does one carry out this
in the context of public libraries
and more of a libraries apparatus.
- Okay, anybody else wants
to raise the question
'cause I've got quite a few more.
Since the Bibliobus was
catering to both French
and Vietnamese readers,
what was the difference in the materials
that were being circulated?
For French, for example,
were they mostly for
entertainment purposes,
you know, reading for leisure?
For Vietnamese, was there a
more educational propaganda
element to it?
I mean, how would we
know how to differentiate
and what was the decision-making process
for, you know, choosing what
book to carry to the provinces?
- Thank you so much for that question.
It's a really hard question to answer
given the archival records,
but how I understand it
was that often,
so the reason why I also
discussed the space limitations
in the Cochinchina library reading room
was that there were only 44 seats.
And in actuality, the reading
room was constantly full.
There were a lot of readers
actually got turned away.
So this is urban readers were turned away,
and the lending section
was incredibly popular
because of the limited space for readers
to actually read in place.
So often readers then borrowed
books to read somewhere else
not in the actual reading room.
So my understanding is
that the lending section
is what then continues to be
circulated into the provinces.
So these lending section collections,
the goal of the library
was that they hoped
that they would reflect
larger kind of demands
and reader tastes.
So I think this is one of the challenges,
and I think those who are in libraries,
work in libraries could
speak to this as well
is that libraries have
two interwoven tensions.
And I think you also quote references too
which is the initiative
to preserve or to conserve
and to circulate.
And at times those
could work hand in hand,
but then if you are,
essentially the more you circulate a work,
the more they actually,
the books get destroyed.
And the more that you
have to put more attention
into actual like preservation.
So they are like two interwoven missions.
And then the, and then those, that mission
basically underlies the
quote unquote success
of a library is that the
library is extensively used
really well.
It's circulated really
well, but it also preserves
and builds a large collection
that reflects certain
collecting practices.
And the collecting
practices and philosophy
of what to collect was in
principle very idealistic,
reflecting this sense
of, like I was saying
with Paul Boudet is something that's like
has collected all levels of knowledge,
as extremely comprehensive,
reflects primarily
the understanding of what
is considered valuable
which is modeled upon
French notions of value.
So that's a lot of classics.
A lot of works, encyclopedias
were collected as well.
A lot of volumes.
There was an attempt to
build large collections
of what was considered like the essential,
the essential works.
At the same time, there
were also other reflections
of what was interesting
which is contemporary,
more contemporary materials
that are published in Indochina,
in the actual print sphere.
So that could be bulletins that
could be other periodicals.
And then the lending section
to answer your question
was then built off of
more recent publications,
and often the collections policy
and what circulated was often random
based on donations,
based on cheap editions
of what is popular.
And thus that is, that becomes cheaper.
So for example, you have many editions
of what you see as global best-sellers
such as "The Count of Monte Cristo,"
"The Three Musketeers,"
seen as kind of pop,
not high class, high level literature,
but readily available.
And those end up being
circulated much more readily
and in the Bibliobus
because they're cheaper
and then there's many editions of them.
- All right, thanks Cindy.
Next we have a couple hands raised here,
and Paul Sarno was the first person
that raised his hand in here.
So please go ahead.
- Yes, I wanted to ask you.
I saw those beautiful colonial buildings
that constituted libraries,
especially the one I saw in Cambodia.
I think it had a date 1924 or so.
What's happened to those buildings?
And what's happened to the contents?
And if you could start with
the Cambodian structure,
I'd be interested.
- Thank you so much, Paul.
And this is where the Cambodia case is one
that I feel very regretful about mainly
because I was supposed
to do field research
in the Cambodian library this past summer,
but then that didn't end up happening
amongst many other things.
But from what I understand
is that that actually
that building is now the archives,
the National Archives of Cambodia.
And that is, in that sense,
it retained its administrative apparatus.
But then, I mean, this is,
there's a lot of this is
like through conversations
with my mentor Penny Edwards
and the importance of actually,
the need to do this type of work.
Because like during the Khmer Rouge,
like this area, this building
was, of course not used,
but then like had other, was
occupied for different reasons
from and then some of the
materials were either destroyed
or, and at times actually
destruction of library materials
happens due to neglect,
not necessarily out of intention.
So a lot of the materials,
as many of you know,
who have done work in Southeast Asia
because of the humidity,
because of all like the bugs
and the insects, then get
degraded quite quickly
especially because of the papers.
So a lot of the materials
are not in great condition.
The Cambodian case too is interesting
because the attempt to
build this elaborate
Directorate of Archives and Library system
in the five areas of Indochina
really was this aspirational aspect
where, you know, the Hanoi
Central Library would be
almost like the equivalent
of a national library,
and it had these subsequent
other headquarters
based on the different countries.
So you have Tonkin, you have Annam,
you have Cochinchina in the
South, and then you have Laos
and you have Cambodge, and
they were supposed to have
like their own specific headquarters.
So the Cambodge case is one.
The Cochinchina Library
library is another,
and then North central library.
There were attempts to
build one north and in Laos
but then those didn't really pick up.
However, the Cambodia case is interesting
because there was two
parallel major libraries
that developed.
The picture, that beautiful
library that you noted,
that actually uses more
of a neoclassical style
in terms of the facade.
This library that was supposed to reflect
this administrative colonial
library in Phnom Penh.
But at the same time, Suzanne
Karpelès was working closely
with the Buddhist Institute
and the Royal Library
which had, which kind of predated
the administrative library.
So there were two libraries
that were existing.
One that the administrative library
which was primarily
serving administrators,
but kind of lost its sense
of purpose in a sense.
Like it didn't have a full,
a public facing library function.
It was more of a
reference, administrative,
almost seemed more like an
archive for administrators.
And then the Royal Library then became,
the Royal Library and
Buddhist Institute was more
as part of the vision to
popularize print and Khmer script
and part of nationalizing Buddhism,
like that, that was the initiative
that like Suzanne Karpelès
was deeply involved in.
And that kind of carried
out through the lens
more of cultural heritage, as
well as religious preservation
and ways of building a vernacular
print sphere in Cambodia.
So then there's like two library systems
that are very different in Cambodia.
And I hope to continue to do my work.
And expand into projects in Cambodia.
I just, at this moment, that's
kind of my understanding
of the institutional history.
- ThanK you.
- All right.
So next up, we have Eric Harns,
and then Al Lim and Michelle Thompson
and also Dr. Noltan Yan.
Cindy Nguyen has agreed
to go a little bit longer
than the 1:00 p.m., so we'll
keep those questions going.
So Eric, go ahead.
- Thanks, Cindy.
This is just so fascinating,
such interesting work that you're doing,
and I just wanna congratulate
you on the project overall
and for a nice presentation today too.
When you mentioned about Paul Boudet
and this idea of wanting to compete
with the illicit reading
material, you know,
like the Bibliobus and the
library system in general
it seems, right?
It made me want to know more
about the illicit materials,
and Hue-Tam already asked the question
I was thinking of at first, you know,
like about the journalism,
but it also did open up another question
I was thinking about like, well,
what are all the things
that people are reading
that are illicit and where
are they getting them?
And how's it circulating?
Because I remember when
reading about journalism,
one of the things I think
in Hue-Tam's book actually,
you know, Nguyễn An Ninh
publishes "La Cloche Fêlée,"
and it has a certain, you
know, number of printed copies,
but of course people are getting one copy
and like 40 people are reading
it or something like that,
you know, a whole bunch of people are.
And so the, in a sense, it's
kind of like a local library,
like they're, like a kind of
Bibliobus of the people, right?
And so I'm just wondering,
like, what are people buying?
Where are they going?
What are the bookstores like in all this?
Is there also regulation of what's sold
in the bookstores and all of that?
And so a general description
of the reading public and
other forms of circulation
would be really great to hear briefly.
- Thank you, Eric.
And I think this is where,
this is very much deeply on my mind
is how do I place the libraries
within this larger
ecosystem of print sphere?
Because of course,
individuals are reading widely
from all these different sources from,
as you noted, like bookstores.
They're passing on the materials.
They're participating in new forms
of like serialized storytelling
as well as different types
of journalistic practices.
And I would also like
defer this type of work to
Hue-Tam's tremendous scholarship
in this field as well
in terms of thinking
about journalists' stake
and radicalism as the
ways in which journalism
and the different types
of kind of print forms
allow for these types
of political organizing
as well as forms of literary expression.
Yet I think what is interesting about the,
kind of the libraries
in this larger ecosystem
is that it has, so there's
because of the ways in which
the libraries was organized,
of course, it was funded
by the governmental state.
It had this deeply archival
preservation mentality
of both collecting what was
considered like works of value
both based on a French notion of value.
And then also there was
a preservation mentality
where not only was the library operated
as the archives and as
these public libraries,
but it also operated as the legal deposit.
So that means that in principle,
every work that was officially
filed for publication
in Indochina, one copy needed to be filed
in the regional library.
So if something is published in Saigon,
one copy needed to be filed
in the Saigon Cochinchina library,
and then one copy needed to be submitted
to the Hanoi Central
Library into the Book Depot.
And then one other copy
needed to be submitted
to the legal deposit in the
National Library in Paris.
And this is where with John McHale's work
where he analyzed a lot of
the legal deposit works,
that's how those collections were built.
So in principle that
reflects a certain slice
of what was the print,
reading, production,
literary, journalistic, print production
from the 20s to the 40s during Vietnam.
And McHale has pointed
to like how it showcases
a lot of like Buddhist's
writing material, for example,
as well as kind of other
forms of literary genres,
satire, and then satire
as well as like fiction
and things like that.
However, what's interesting when you look
about the materials
that are in the library,
so you have this like these books
of which are considered
quote unquote classics,
and then you have these new forms
of Indochina published materials,
new as in things that are
contemporarily printed
rather than retroactively preserved,
and how they differ
from what is basically
sold on the streets.
And it's not always a blur,
like a distinct separation
because some of the most
popular works as I was saying
make their way into the library too
because there's just
so many copies of them.
They end up getting added into the library
because of its popularity.
However, there was still,
library acquisitions still
went through a process
of somewhat,
of indirect censorship,
which is that those of
which was not seen as
well, as seen as more
political or radicalizing
didn't end up in the library.
So it's the other material that ended up
kind of circulating in
bookstores and being retranslated
or rewritten and republished
in different editions.
What's interesting is I have lists
of things of which are books,
of which kind of accidentally
end up in the library
of which shouldn't have been there
which is really interesting because then
it kind of points to that
this regime of control was much weaker
than we anticipate,
which is often the case.
So for example, like
Nguyễn An Ninh translated
Rousseau's "Social Contract."
And that circulated in the
library for quite some time.
And it wasn't, it was
debated as to like how risky
or dangerous these works were.
But then it kind of, when it was found,
it was immediately pulled
from the library, for example.
Or there's other like biographies
of Chinese nationalists.
So I think those are like,
that's a quintessential example
of the illicit reading
of which is circulating.
And that also ended up in the library
and then immediately got flagged as well.
There were also initiatives to
start like smaller libraries
and to officially open a library
and have it recognized by the state,
you had to publicly post what the library,
even if it was like an association,
you had to publicly post
what materials were in there.
And often, so then the colonial state
was trying to police these cases
of like these illicit
libraries that are opening
without official registration.
And then it's often lists of these,
either like biographies of revolutionaries
that are circulating, a
lot of political tracts,
criticisms, explicit
criticisms of the state.
I think pretty like overtly
anti-colonial texts.
And those libraries nearly tried to,
were shut down or policed.
I realize there's so many questions,
and I hope is there a way that
I could also save the chat?
So feel free to please also
throw things in the chat.
- There are some questions in the chat,
and then let's see in the participants,
Al Lin has also raised his hand.
- Oh, okay.
- [Quan] Go ahead.
- Hi, thank you so much for this talk.
It's super, super
fascinating to hear about.
I'm thinking a lot about
Anderson and national identity.
I love the kind of quote
from Viet's article
talking about civility and the connection
between linguistic and national identity.
I mean, I even think that print culture
is that alternative to print capitalism
that Chatterjee kind of critiques.
And so thinking about print
culture instead of capitalism
as a much more nuanced way to think about
kind of like national
identity and formation,
and I'm wondering how
successful were libraries
as part of articulating national identity?
So in so much that they do,
how do we measure its success?
Especially I guess with
the decolonization chapter,
and one way to think about it.
I love that you mentioned
that Laos, for example,
didn't have a library.
So how did they, for example,
articulate national identity
as part of, without a kind
of equivalent library?
And then also thinking
about how folks are like
colonial authorities
have different agendas.
So they're trying to like articulate
a kind of forceful kind of like a position
of certain things versus like borrowers
who are like borrowing books
and not necessarily thinking
about national identity
in that way.
So it's just a lot of, I
guess, a lot of moving parts.
And I think to Eric's previous question,
this idea about repression
like censorship,
like a Foucaultian take,
like the more you oppress,
that doesn't really work in that way.
So the more colonial people
try to articulate national identity
that ends up kind of working
in very different ways.
So I'm just wondering how do we track kind
of that relationship between, yeah,
nationalism and libraries?
- Thank you so much, Al.
You've asked many layers of questions
of which I hope to be able
to answer or articulate
in different ways.
So as a brief answer, one question
that I'm working through right now
was actually taken from
this close analysis
of this Khuong Viet piece,
is the connection
between national identity
and linguistic identity.
And this is something that
underlines so much of my project
which is as I'm tracing the
history of the libraries
and thinking to Eric's question,
even Hue-Tam's question
about like what makes the
library kind of different
in this larger ecosystem of other books?
Is that the story of
the library in Indochina
is also the story,
like it has, I would say two
other intertwined stories,
which is one on education
and two on language.
And I would argue that
especially thinking about decolonization
and like let's take the specific instance
of the Cochinchina Library
of which underwent extensive
processes of decolonization
in the 50s, and then got in 54 to 55
with the division of
North and South Vietnam,
the Saigon or the Cochinchina
Library inherited a third
of the French colonial
collections in Hanoi,
as well as all the staff
and the University of Hanoi.
So there were all these
colonial institutions
that then were physically, logistically
moved down to Saigon.
And then Saigon, the Cochinchina Library,
this tiny, already cramped library
inherited this collection.
And it wasn't just like a physical merger,
but from the fifth,
actually really earlier
from like 45 to, and
especially through 49,
the Cochinchina Library
as it was going through this
process of de-colonization
is trying to articulate how
do we distinguish ourselves
from our colonial past
but also we are inheriting all
of these colonial vestiges,
French language materials, for example,
a lot of materials about in the archives
about the colonial state.
So how do we distinguish
ourselves as a Vietnamese nation,
and this process as we understand through
studying the Republic of Vietnam
and also through the war was constantly
trying to distinguish itself
from North Vietnam too
which is at, the South Vietnam and Saigon
was trying to articulate itself as this,
as this national cultural
heritage preserver
of the legitimate form of
all Vietnamese identity.
And that, and this is where I argue
that the library played
a very key part in this.
So because it inherited all
these colonial materials,
it also sought and advocated
that this was part of its mission
was that we are preserving
this long history
of all of Vietnamese history,
kind of symbolized through
inheriting this collection,
inheriting actually some of
the precolonial collections
that were also preserved in Hanoi.
And then additionally,
looking into the present
and to the future,
which is that we needed,
as a library you needed to advocate
and transform language acquisition
or like the acquisition
of materials in Vietnamese
rather than in French.
So there was, there was a huge shift
to nationalize the library
through the collection
of adamantly searching out
and adding all Vietnamese
materials that were published,
newly published in the 50's and 60's,
as well as building collections
like Chinese language collections
as well as part of the Saigon library.
And this is where kind of
going back to your question
of how does one articulate
this national identity,
I would argue is it's
very closely intertwined
with these language policies
as well as the library,
especially this case
of the Saigon Library,
symbolically functioning as this fortress,
like I think the quote
said a fortress of culture.
And a fortress of culture and heritage
that really articulated
a national identity
kind of looking forward but
also looking to its past, right?
So looking to preserve and create
this kind of streamlined understanding
of what was considered
legitimate Vietnamese national identity.
I think I'll stop there because
I can keep going with this
because it's such a
fascinating way of framing.
And thank you so much for that question.
- All right, we have
Michelle Thompson next
and then after Michelle, Dr. Norton Yan.
- Hi, this was just
really a wonderful talk,
and I was very happy to
see it on the schedule
because it kind of connects
with some work I did earlier
on what gets put into an
archive and what does not.
I was focusing mainly on no.
I originally had several
questions for you,
but you've kind of addressed some of them
in the question and answer period.
But one thing that hasn't been touched on,
but just was just barely
brought up in your answer
just a minute ago is connected to staff.
And there's a wonderful
novel I read a few years ago,
and I'm trying to remember
the exact name of it,
but it's about a woman
in the early 20th century
in the United States who fought
to get to be allowed to
be a part of the staff
of a library in the Appalachian mountains
who was delivering books
to people on horseback.
She literally had a
route like a mail route
that she covered like once
every couple of weeks or so.
It's a really great novel, but you know,
I thought I would just like
to hear you talk a little bit
about the staff.
I mean, we don't,
you didn't really say anything about say
gender makeup of the staff
or, you know, effects on them,
effects of them on their
own communities, et cetera.
So I'd like to hear you talk a little bit
about the staff of these libraries.
- Thank you so much.
I'm so glad you brought this question up.
This was like the subject of my,
one of my other talks where I
just talked about the people.
So tracing the librarians and the staff
was a very complicated endeavor
because there was frequent
turnover in low-level staff.
And this would include
from secretaries, copyists,
typists, groundskeepers, those
who are maintaining security
and operations of the building.
But I think what's fascinating about
in a lot of this
discussion about the staff
and the personnel and
extensive record keeping
about the personnel is
that there was this,
there was this kind of vibrant world
of librarian low-level staff who were,
who were the primary
readers of the library
because they worked there.
They checked out the books the most,
and you see this, especially
in the Saigon library,
and it's in these,
they'll be the ones who are constantly,
they'll be in the book checkout records.
And then they actually, because
they worked in the library
end up kind of defying the restrictions
of like only checking
out two books at a time,
to check out four for example.
And then in one of my
chapters in the 1930s,
there's an extensive discussion
about how high level staff
which are primarily French-trained,
so either at Chartres,
like that's at the highest
level of the administrators
as like the Director of like, for example,
the Saigon library, and then
the lower level librarians
either that are French,
like racially French,
end up coming into the library,
either working from like
other administrative governmental offices.
So if they're not officially
trained in library sciences
then they are trained in
other governmental work,
and then you have
Vietnamese librarian staff
who either have come in
because they've, I think in,
like Khuong Viet technically
worked in the Saigon library
before, and he actually
was very much involved,
I think, Hue-Tam pointed to this too,
but involved in other literacy societies
in Quốc Ngữ, popularization societies.
Some are involved as like
self-taught linguists.
They're, they have like
a scholar bureaucrat
type of identity.
Oh, but then the discussion
I was talking about
was like in the 30's,
there was this rampant
extensive discussion between
tension between high-level
staff and low-level staff
because there were often
accusations against low-level staff
for stealing books because
they have the most access
to the library collections.
So they, the low-level
staff were often seen
as suspect from high-level staff.
And, yeah, so and then were dismissed
because of other tensions or kind of,
how would I describe this,
as kind of disconnects between
different working cultures?
So for example, people showing up late
or people defying the library rules,
coming on weekends,
coming when it's closed.
So using this space in
ways that were intended.
So these are library staff
like living in this space,
like after hours, not leaving,
bringing in their friends,
like things of which were seen
as defying a very kind of rigid policy
of library preservation
or kind of not being as attentive
to like recording checkouts, for example.
So I have a lot of these,
what I see as these everyday
dramas of library staff
amongst each other, but
also tensions between,
like I have a case for
example, of a French reader
in the Hanoi central library
who basically physically attacked
a low-level Vietnamese librarian
because that librarian would
not bundle up his books
that he checked out.
So then the French administrator,
or the French reader patron
punched the librarian,
and then the librarian staff
ended up like reporting this
to a higher administration.
But then there was no kind
of type of like consequences
for these, this type of behavior.
And then that really points
to the racial hierarchies
within reading of these, of the libraries.
So I have so many of
these stories, Michelle,
I think it's just,
it really I'm trying to
still make sense of them
just because it, they're
are so nuanced and textured.
Oh, and then the other one
I wanted to mention also
is gender, is that the
majority of the library staff
were male, and low-level were
definitely racially Vietnamese
but then often the discussion
about hiring Vietnamese librarian
or sorry female librarian staff
was seen as a question also of,
it was race and gender
questions because it costs more
to hire a female, a
French female librarian,
even though, and then a lot
of French female librarians
ended up being secretaries,
but then over time because of the costs
of paying French administrators
or French library administrators
there is a shift to train more
Vietnamese administrators.
And then those were,
ended up often being male.
I think I'll end there
because I could go into another story
about Suzanne Karpeles,
but I think I'll stop here.
- Okay, and we'll have time
for maybe one last question
from Dr. Norton Yan.
And if you still have
questions for Cindy Nguyen,
please drop them in the chat,
and we'll share those with her later.
- This is a question
that related to Michelle,
because classification,
there are a lot of classification
in the library and some of
them are pre-classification.
That means acquisition.
And then the classification
in Vietnam is very complex
through the Russian system.
And then through the American system,
the Dewey system and MARC 21.
I am doing a lot of village documentation.
And then it will be like
to bypass all of that.
And then to go directly into a computer.
To library online is
probably have to go to
along with a library organization,
so that they don't have to fire staff.
And then if staff feeling that they fired,
then they would resist on change.
That is one of my questions,
and I hope to know that
what kind of classification
were used in the libraries
in Vietnam and Cambodia.
- Thank you so much for this question.
Definitely you're pointing to
the complex information
systems that were used
over the different processes,
over the colonial and
the post-colonial time.
So during the colonial period,
they followed the Bibliothèque nationale,
the French model of classifications,
and then this was thematically
organized as well as,
so there were two catalogs that were used,
one by theme by topic,
and then one by author.
And then these cataloging systems
as the libraries continued to grow,
it wasn't always updated.
So like the author catalog for example
was definitely not updated as much,
and it kind of fell apart.
So often the classification system
during the colonial period
was in principal modeled that way.
But then in practice, a lot of the,
there were also other aspects
of the library reading room
where there were books of
which were on the shelves
for free perusal.
So often these were like
more like reference,
encyclopedia as well as
contemporary periodicals
that were available.
And then there were
separate lending sections
which operated their own kind of,
and these are collections
of about 10,000 works,
and these would operate with a theme
or a topic-oriented catalog
and then author catalog.
What's interesting is by the 50's,
there was an attempt to implement
the Dewey decimal system
as well, as well as to
put the Saigon library
more within kind of
international library standards.
And then at the same time,
as you're mentioning as well,
is that the DRV in Hanoi,
the library then was directly
using the Russian, the BBK,
the BBK classification system
that followed like,
well Soviet as well as socialist notions
of information organizing.
So I believe I haven't looked
at the classification system
in a while, but how I
understand it is I think
the first three are like Marx, Lenin,
ways of which are like, are more about
like socialist forms of
knowledge and information.
Is that right?
- Yeah.
- Okay, so, and then,
and now how I understand
it too, is that, gosh,
I think the last time
the old card catalogs
were still usable in the Hanoi,
the national library in Hanoi,
because it followed the
former cataloging system
from the French period.
Then there was a process
to put them into this,
the socialist system.
And then after that now, it's
going through another system
of which it's having issues because of
putting it into the catalog.
But I think you're right in pointing out
like the layered ways in which
these classification systems
actually create this
disarray of the documentation
and point to kind of also
the different organizing
or intellectual processes
that underlie organizing information
during these different historical periods.
- [Dr. Nhan] Thank you,
thank you very much.
- Thank you for all of
these wonderful questions
and Cindy for answering them.
That will wrap it up for the day.
So please join me in thanking Cindy Nguyen
for this amazing and fantastic
project that she's had done.
- Thank you so much.
What great questions.
Thank you.